up a toi aller à s'émousser vous allez
allez hop à toi allez allez allez allez
bonsoir oui qu'est ce qui t'arrive
faisait me souviens de recevoir une
lettre qui est l extraordinaire à sa
casimir armure choix tous les jours
d'état celle ci n'est pas comme les
autres écoute écoute
monsieur casimir a ayant entendu parler
de vous en termes très forts avec
casimir tu vois qu'il ya des gens qui
disent du bien de toi
attends attends tu vas voir la suite je
sollicite donc l'autorisation de pouvoir
vous rencontrer
en tout cas casimir c'est une personne
qui écrit très très bien train et
pourquoi cette personne ne veut-elle
venir te voir à temps c'est là que ça
devient et non tu vas voir je crois que
je peux faire de vous la plus célèbre
vos dettes du monde
je prends aujourd'hui même le train puis
le bateau pour venir vous rencontrer
signée albert travelling imprésario
gravelines imprésario c'est quand même
un drôle de nom le nom qui fait du
mélange tout
son nom est albert travelling et son
métier celui d'un imprésario
c'est un métier ça va évidemment un
après sérieux c'est une personne qui est
chargé de trouver du travail aux
artistes et tu crois qu'il va me trouver
du travail
peut-être enfin si devenir un artiste
n'est évidemment pas tout bref de
devenir à un grand artiste n'est ce pas
c'est casimir pour devenir un grand
artiste faut pas avoir peur de
travailler je te promet françois dès que
je sors est un grand artiste
1 je travaillerai avec et similitudes tu
inverse complètement le problème c'est
pas une fois qu'on est devenu un grand
artiste célèbre qu'il faut se mettre à
travailler ses avants pour le devenir
lorelei faut travailler très très dur
si tu veux un jour avoir une petite
chance d'y arriver
j'espère qu'ils arriveront série c'est
bien lui
dans mes bras c'est regrettable mais
tant que ça mais merci oui tu as entendu
il m'a appelé grand artiste mais ça ne
veut pas dire grand chose c'est une
habitude du spectacle je me présente
albert travelling le plus grand
imprésario du monde je m'en doutais et
et moi je suis casimir vous avez
aussitôt reconnu mon flair me trompe
jamais j'ai découvert des dizaines
d'artistes célèbres avant vous vous êtes
extraordinaire savez vous par exemple
que j'ai fait de mes propres mains
la carrière du grand adolphe ramolino si
vous formidable parlons est cher ami je
n'ai que très peu de temps je vous ai
apporté un contrat de vedettes à
monsieur travelling casimir ne peut pas
signer comme ça parce qu'il ne s'est pas
eu crime très bien très bien qu'il fasse
une croix sa passion je voulais diriger
travelling chez travelling je ne sais
même pas ce que casimir sait faire et
vous lui proposer un contrat
quelques jours mais oui enfin je sais
chanter je sais danser je sais jouer
plein de roullens tenait attendait voilà
installé vous même monsieur très pressés
à mais je ne signerai que lorsque vous
mourrez vu trop beau bonjour garde
lombarde
voilà alors tout d'abord je vais je vais
chanter
attention musica
avec une chanson
un peu d'imagination
vous emmène dans notre it is pays du
bonheur tranquille
ce comburant compris ne soyez pas
terrorisé je suis le monstre qui fait
rire
ap
j'ai une machine est une idée
fantastique je mange
bluebeam une gamme mais je n'en ai pas
marre j'ai vu dans mon camion
cinéma4 toi c'est mon droit et tous ses
droits
[Musique]
alors qu'en pensez vous oh ah bon eh
bien je sais aussi dense et on va les
voir attention un deux trois
[Musique]
on
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors bon bien bien moi attendez minutes
j'aurais cherché ma malle magique
il va nous aller voir les enfants
casimir va jouer plusieurs personnages
pour monsieur travelling voulait bien
essayer de deviner quelles sont ses
personnages
oui d'accord à toi casimir
vous êtes parent premiers rôles à tence
porthos et aramis mes amis nous allons
combattre les gardes du cardinal tous
pour un un pour tous a très bien casimir
de qui s'agitent et les ophones de
d'artagnan effectivement tous pour un un
pour tous tous pour tous pouvait lire
aussi ci mais termiste monsieur
travelling qu'en pensez vous alors on
peut déjà vu bon eh bien j'ai un
douzième rôle alors attention deuxième
rôle bien avec moi cheetah nous allons
sauver jane des mains des bandits
[Musique]
alors les enfants et ça c'est un an et
qui chuta tâche à poser bravo monsieur
travelling car il arrive plus minables
non aux contrats commerciaux
ah bon il coûtait juin 3e all vous allez
voir attention troisième rôle
attention sergent garcia
je vais vous coupez les moustaches aa
alors les enfants c'est au fait ça alors
ça vous a plu
home ce ne sont pas des rôles pour vous
mais nous menons la journée le rôle qui
vous permettra de couvrir le monde sous
les bravos grâce à moi votre nom sera
inscrit en lettres énormes sur les
musicaux de paris new york londres tokyo
balbronn vous promettre d'étonner
casimir casimir attend tiens tiens
casimir tu sais quel est le rôle que te
réserve de monsieur travelling le rôle
du prince charmant
voilà pas du tout fait cet émir écoute
écoute tulle être engagée comme un
horrible monstre très féroce et présenté
dans toutes les villes du monde dans une
cage enchaîné lawrence avec les mois
horribles effet rançon vous allez voir
monsieur travelling moi aussi j'ai un
rôle pour vous avez bien ne bougeait pas
c'est le rôle du sergent garcia
et moi je vais vous coupez les mousses
tara avec mon geste fou
[Musique]